my Rudolph and Kristen Wigg brought the
laughs at the Academy Awards Sunday
night I can't do it because we're upset
Oh are we upset and it was comedy gold
from the jump that was an act we were
acting after showcasing their dramatic
acting chops the two broke into song and
one of these days these boots the
audience couldn't get enough of the
musical number
but Billy eyelashes reactions stood out
Renegado and Monroe Dietrich
[Music]
Billy's face looked perplexed with
cameras catching her quickly looking up
and away now Billy might have been
throwing a little side eye shade but
we've got a note she also lives with
Tourette's syndrome which can cause her
to make uncomfortable facial expressions
something she opened up to Ellen
DeGeneres last year about I'm sitting
there answering the questions like AHA
and then they they start asking me
questions I'm like and then everyone's
like that's so funny and they made a
whole there's tons of compilations like
this is so funny that Billy did this
face looks yeah when really it's just a
bunch of tics right Billy kept her
diagnosis a secret at the start of her
career until she realized she could help
others I think I also really learned
that like a lot of my friends have it I
felt like there was a connection there I
felt like when I said that there were
kids that were posting and being like oh
my god I've always had this yeah now she
has it and she's who I can look up to
with it but back to the Oscars Billy
also took to the stage to perform during
the in memoriam tribute which honored
Kobe Bryant it's not about me this is
about them
that's beautiful it's a very listen it's
a great thing to do but it's a very
difficult thing to do as well to
everybody I know they've added something
special for Colby can you tell us
anything or how did you how did that
affect your planning what's going to be
playing it's like every time I see his
face I'm like you can have the best time
ever to know yeah we're excited
do us a favor give us your Oscars look
in the camera
your Oscars law
[Music]